there's really funny stuff from Donald
Trump's Twitter account yesterday Trump
is now referring to Fox News as quote we
so either Trump sees himself as part of
Fox News or more likely and more
realistically Trump sees Fox News as the
media arm of his administration which it
has been since day one and there are
actually two hilarious things in this
one tweet that I'm going to show you and
I don't know which is funnier Trump
claiming that Fox News treated Bernie
too nicely in their Town Hall or
referring to Fox News as we Trump said
quote so weird to watch crazy Bernie on
Fox News not surprisingly Bret bear and
the quote audience was so smiley and
nice very strange and now we have Donna
Brazile so let's get one part out of the
way here trump sees fox as being on his
team because they are trump
overwhelmingly appears on fox news
trumps daily tweet storms are often sort
of dictated by what fox news happens to
be covering he regularly talks to sean
hannity so we get it Trump and Fox are
intertwined a lot of what Trump thinks
he knows about politics came from Fox
News the talking points the slogans the
points of view I don't even want to
spend that much time on that because
there's a much funnier and an
interesting thing in Donald Trump's
tweet which is that he's claiming Bernie
Sanders was treated to fairly during the
town hall that took place earlier this
week Monday night the first question
came from a turning point USA campus
organizer a right-wing group got to ask
the first question at the Bernie Town
Hall the entire Town Hall was Martha
McCallum and Bret Baier trying to get
Bernie with gotcha questions and
becoming argumentative and teaming up on
Bernie Sanders they asked them is Joe
Biden a progressive they asked him why
aren't you choosing to send more money
to the IRS if you think taxes should be
higher they miss stated his positions
time after time after time they asked
him about late term abortion in a
cartoonish right-wing way that was
completely deceptive and lastly let's
put the tweet back up first
second here he also mentions crazy
Burnie which barely requires a comment
but as an aside
tell me again which of Bernie's ideas is
crazy again because if Bernie's crazy 90
percent of the rich countries in the
world west are crazy
everybody gets health care wow that is
nuts we work to reduce inequality that
is crazy Bernie we prioritize education
we tax those who are incredibly rich and
have benefited from the system that we
have barely even worth discussing at
this point because if you don't get it
you're probably not going to but for me
Pat a big deal was made out of the we
have done a Brazil now it almost could
be just one of those ways where Trump
says now we as a society have Donna
Brazile on fox news i don't think that's
the biggest part the craziest part is
that Trump thinks Bernie was treated too
nicely during a town hall that was
completely slanted against him yeah I
guess there's a lot to say here I mean
just because Bernie crushed it at the
Fox News Town Hall that doesn't mean
that he was treated fairly he certainly
was treated unfairly and just performed
well uh and you know Trump admitting
that he is part of Fox News that's a
long time coming Fox dropped the fair
and balanced moniker about two years ago
he's just kind of saying it out in the
open we already knew this yeah there's
nothing actually surprising here other
than Trump seems to have a completely
sheltered disconnected in myopic view of
reality and that includes his
perceptions of what's going on on
corporate media even corporate media
that has gone out of its way to kowtow
and cater to Donald Trump's harebrained
ideas in completely ridiculous policies
and Trump says oh they're being too nice
to Bernie Sanders who yeah I mean Bernie
did kill it but Bernie killed it because
he's simply stating ideas that make
sense and no matter how you try to sort
of caricature those ideas even if you're
a professional page fill like Martha
McCallum or Bret Baier Bernie's idea
still makes sense and there's nothing
that Fox News could do about that today
the David Pakman show was made possible
in part by Nordby PN which is a tool
that I've been using on my computer and
my phone to protect my privacy online
and
keep my personal data safe because it
allows you to change your device's IP
address making you totally anonymous on
the internet and Nord VPN is giving
everybody in our audience a 75% discount
on a three-year subscription this comes
out to less than three bucks a month
plus a whole month free when you go to
Nordby PN com slash David Pakman and use
the coupon code david pakman all one
word we know that the david pakman show
has a lot of viewers in Europe and
article 13 of the European Union
copyright directive was just passed
which has been an extremely
controversial piece of legislation among
the YouTube community because it
requires YouTube and other video sharing
platforms to crack down on copyright in
even harsher ways and there are still a
lot of unanswered questions about what
effects this law is going to have
YouTube videos might even be blocked in
Europe and this type of thing is
something else that Nord VPN is perfect
for if content is being censored where
you live Nord VPN lets you change your
IP address so that it looks like you're
connecting to the internet from a
totally different geographical location
and you circumvent these types of
heavy-handed content bans and censorship
but there's lots of other advantages as
well you're making yourself a lot less
susceptible to being hacked it makes it
harder for creepy social media websites
to follow you around the internet when
you use Nord VPN you and what you're
doing online stay totally anonymous and
david pakman show viewers can get 75%
off a three-year plan of Nord VPN that's
under three bucks a month plus one whole
month totally free just by going to Nord
VPN dot-com slash David Pakman I've put
the link underneath this video then just
use the coupon code david pakman at
checkout all one word